what's the process of what you do that
we don't see a good question
with me being you know producer before I
can direct I need to go out there and
either if it's my film blocking an
investor or lock in a budget and a lot
of time me the filmmaker I'm spending 80
percent of the time finding an executive
producer or locking in funds and 20% of
the time creating the film but I want to
switch it around while I'm spending 80
percent of the time shooting the movie
the only 20 percent of the time
locking in the investor so what people
don't see is before I get to the set
they don't know what I had to go through
to lock in a producer or lock in a
budget be able to hire everybody be able
to feed everybody be able to have a
situation for us to shoot this month
like no one sees the business behind the
scene side of it you see like oh we're
shooting on the red cameras oh we're
working with a Vedic era or Malik we'd
fill today you know what I mean like
they just see the the physical glitz and
glamour part of it they don't really see
like me in my home office on the phone
or in the email
conjuring up you know potential deals or
potential relationships that leads to
you know producing movies or
what-have-you so yeah people don't see
that part if people just think like oh
the cameras just shows up and in the
craft service and everything this pays
for itself and you know what I mean well
I mean I don't think they think that but
it's people just don't see like what it
takes to get and a production like
finance and going in and you know and
meeting deadlines and stuff is it looks
easy and it looks like we're having fun
on set when we're working with you know
certain you know talent and certain
equipment and stuff but it's not easy
it just looks easy and going back to
that one set in 95 when you were doing
craft services did you think that it was
easy from watching your friend you know
what it did look easy I remember being
19 or 20 I was 20
yeah I was 20 95 and I remember my boy
Daniel sitting in the chair
the director chair and all this dude was
saying was action action action I'm like
yo benefited like that's all is he doing
is just like you know I mean like
directing Italian and the talent is
doing everything and he made me figure
out how to get in that chair and it was
not easy at all
it looks easy once trying to send you
like a real camera roll sound
we got speed are in action all that
stuff you're not saying looks funny easy
but no one knows that you had the first
of all have a body of work to even have
booked a job that was going on you need
to have a real you need to have a
website you needed to say they're the
right thing and answer the questions you
know professionally and in art you know
and speak our ticket Lee you know what I
mean and everything like matters before
you get to the set and some people don't
realize like you know
it takes a lot of hard work to get in
that director's chair to be you know
working with big names or big companies
you know what I mean like it takes it
takes a lot of success to get to that
point
you